[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend das
von den Erdbeben erschütterte Gebiet ist
riesig allein in der Türkei sind mehr
als 13 Millionen Menschen betroffen für
zehn Provinzen wurde der Notstand
ausgerufen so verwundert es auch nicht
dass nicht überall gleichzeitig genügend
Rettungskräfte eintreffen die auch noch
entsprechend ausgestattet sind in vielen
Gegenden ist es schon schwierig
überhaupt dorthin zu kommen kaputte und
vereiste Straßen und Brücken Schneefall
und Regen machen es den Helfern schwer
bei ihrem Wettlauf gegen die Zeit in den
syrischen Katastrophengebieten kommen
noch ganz andere Probleme hinzu darüber
berichten wir gleich beginnen aber
zunächst in der Türkei
die Straße nach karaman-marash gleicht
einer Eisbahn das ZDF-Team macht halt in
der Kleinstadt göksun viele Häuser sind
zerstört und noch sind keine Hilfstrupps
hier angekommen mit bloßen Händen und
Bohrmaschinen suchen Sie nach
Verschütteten Angehörigen unter den
Trümmern
ich habe gesehen wie sie 45 Leute leben
rausgezogen haben aber da unten liegen
noch sehr viele Tote von denen haben Sie
bisher noch niemanden bergen können
ob Tag oder Nacht es gibt immer wieder
Nachbeben wir leben hier in ständiger
Panik
in ihrer Häuser trauen sie sich nicht
zurück wärmen sich am offenen Feuer und
warten dass endlich Hilfe kommt
am Morgen steigen Drohnen auf Filmen das
ganze Ausmaß der Zerstörungen große
Wohnblocks in der Millionenstadt Hatay
nahe der syrischen Grenze sind nur noch
schuttertaufen
durch ein Loch in der eingestürzten
Betondecke holen sie ein kleines Mädchen
zurück ans Licht über 24 Stunden war sie
verschüttet sie hat das Grauen überlegt
und jede Rettung gibt den Helfern Kraft
und Sinn weiterzumachen
nordöstlich von Hatay in Malatya hat es
die ganze Nacht geschneit der türkische
Katastrophenschutz hat am Rande der
Stadt Zelte aufgebaut für die die ihr zu
Hause verloren haben viele der Opfer
sind wütend und enttäuscht fragen warum
die Hilfe so spät kommt
wenn es ihm in den Kram passt ist
Vaterstadt zur Stelle aber wo ist der
jetzt wir warten hier schon den zweiten
Tag und Flehen um Hilfe
ihr Präsident meldet sich am Nachmittag
aus dem Krisenzentrum in seinem Palast
in Ankara Erklärungsversuche
die Fläche der betroffenen Gebiete ist
sehr groß
die Verwüstungen sind schwer und das
Wetter ist schlecht
deshalb konnten die Rettungsaktionen
nicht so schnell anlaufen wie wir uns
das vorgestellt hatten
deshalb konnten wir auch noch nicht alle
Regionen erreichen
aber ich versichere allen Bürgern dass
der Staat mit all seiner Kraft daran
arbeitet Ihnen zu helfen und ihr Leben
zu retten
der Präsident hatte dafür gestern auch
im ausländische Hilfe gebeten gegen
Mittag treffen erste Kräfte aus
Deutschland ein Suchtrupps mit
Spürhunden der Hilfsorganisation Isa vom
Flughafen Gaziantep wollen Sie weiter
nach Hatay erste Aufgabe wird sein die
Schadensstellen zu sichten und dann mit
den Hunden zugucken ob wir jemanden
finden können ob wir noch jemanden
retten können
wir hoffen dass wir schnell ins
schadengebiet kommen weil wie gesagt
eben das Wetter spielt nicht unbedingt
gut mit wenn es so kalt ist unter den
Trümmern
am Abend sind auch in der Kleinstadt
göksun 30 40 Rettungskräfte angekommen
graben sich durch die Trümmer die
Trümmer eines Hauses von Tausenden in
einer Stadt von vielen Städten in der
zweiten eisigen Nacht
unsere Reporterin eine Brühe ist für uns
im Katastrophengebiet unterwegs und war
den Tag überhaupt in der besonders sehr
Betroffenen Stadt Götzen in der Nähe des
Epizentrums nein das ist ein
Gebirgsgebiet wo ihr unterwegs sind oder
muss es jetzt gerade in der Nacht doch
wirklich Fruchtbarkeit sein
ja es ist Furchtbarkeit und die diese
Kälte ist auch das was hier den Menschen
im Moment am meisten zu schaffen macht
eisige Temperaturen es liegt Schnee es
pfeift einen einen ein Wind die ganze
Zeit wir haben jetzt hier minus gerade
die mehr als -10 Grad und die Menschen
verbringen eben diese zweite Nacht nach
dem schweren Beben im Freien viele in
den Autos weil sie eben Angst von
Nachbeben haben die es hier immer wieder
gibt auch wir haben das heute in den
Bergen erlebt einen Nachbeben der Stärke
5,0 das war schon durchaus beängstigend
und als wir hier zurückgefahren sind aus
dieser Bergregion da haben wir an den
Tankstellen lange Schlangen gesehen
Benzin und Diesel sind knapp die
Menschen versuchen natürlich ihre Autos
voll zu tanken wenn sie dann nachts drin
übernachten dann lassen Sie den Motor
wenigstens ab und anlaufen um am
wenigstens ein bisschen Wärme zu haben
als Schränke wie läuft denn die Hilfe an
was konntest du heute
als wir in die Berge gefahren sind
Richtung Zentrum da hatten wir den
Eindruck die Hilfe erreicht diese Region
erst ganz langsam roter Halbmond aber
auch der nationale Katastrophenschutz
der Türkei schweres Gerät die sind
sozusagen mit uns über diese Bergpässe
Gefahren in die Region und natürlich
werden sie dort dringend erwartet denn
heute Nachmittag das war 36 Stunden nach
dem Beben und natürlich sind da noch
viele Menschen verschüttet die brauchen
dringend Hilfe inzwischen werden in
einigen Orten Zelte errichtet das heißt
man versucht die Menschen wenigstens ins
Warme zu bekommen und ihnen eine
wenigstens einen einen einen eine kleine
Unterkunft bieten zu können die andere
unserer Partnerin aus dem
Erdbebengebieten der Türkei danke schön
eine Brille
immerhin gibt es in der Türkei klare
staatliche Zuständigkeiten und
Strukturen und schnell angelaufene Hilfe
aus dem Ausland im Kriegsland Syrien
sieht das anders aus am schlimmsten ist
es im Norden vor allem in den Gebieten
die von der Opposition gehalten werden
an Hilfslieferungen kommt dort praktisch
nichts an die deutsche Außenministerin
bareburg fordert eine Öffnung aller
Grenze Übergänge im humanitäre Hilfe zu
ermöglichen und appellierte an Russland
seinen Einfluss auf das Regime in
Damaskus gelten zu machen bislang helfen
in den rebellengebieten nur die
sogenannten weißhelme eine private
Organisation des syrischen Zivilschutzes
und es fehlt ihnen an allem berichtet
golini
westlich von Aleppo
dutzende Kinder konnten die
zivilschutzhelfer der weisshelme bisher
retten
immer noch hören sie rufe aus den
Trümmern aber die Zahl der eingestürzten
Häuser ist zu groß die Aufgabe zu
gigantisch für eine einzige kleine
Hilfsorganisation
wir brauchen im Moment alles wir
brauchen räumungsgerät wir brauchen
sofortige Unterstützung wir brauchen
internationale Rettungsteams sofortige
Hilfe
doch nichts davon ist hier bislang
angekommen im Gegenteil in der von
syrischen Rebellen beherrschten Region
die schon vor dem Beben nur durch
Hilfslieferungen überlebte ist die
Lebenslinie der einzige Grenzübergang
zur Türkei aufgrund von zerstörten
Straßen derzeit abgeschnitten
es gibt keinen Staat hier keine
Ausrüstung um die Leute zu retten nicht
genug Bagger wir machen alles nur mit
unseren Händen da sind noch ganze
Familien unter den Trümmern
tote stapeln sich in den Fluren der
Krankenhäuser manche Familien müssen
ihre Verwundeten selbst verarzten es
fehlen Behandlungsgeräte
der Verlust hat mich gebrochen ich habe
keine Familie ich habe niemanden mehr
sagt ein Einwohner der zwölf Menschen
verloren hat
die meisten der rund viereinhalb
Millionen Bewohner hier sind mehrfach
vertriebene die vor syriens Machthaber
Baschar al Assad geflohen sind wer ihnen
hilft das wollen Damaskus und seine
Schutzmacht Russland am liebsten alleine
entscheiden
auch in den vom Assad-Regime
beherrschten Gebieten soll die
Zerstörung groß sein aber es gibt nur
wenige Informationen über das Ausmaß
auch hier ist die Bevölkerung extrem
verarmt auch hier mangelte es schon vor
dem Beben an Treibstoff und Strom
Damaskus kündigte treibstoffhilfen an um
die Bergungsarbeiten voranzubringen
Helfer aus Russland sind angekommen aber
keine internationalen Experten und
Bergungsteams
es Misstrauen ist groß gegenüber
externer Hilfe besonders durch die UN
das möchte das Regime sehr stark
kontrollieren nimmt möglicherweise Geld
sehr gerne das fließt aber dann auch
nicht unbedingt in die Hilfen aber
externer Unterstützung tatsächlich
anzunehmen damit tut es sich sehr schwer
nach zwölf Jahren Krieg sagen viele
Syrer noch nie sei ihre Not so groß
gewesen wie jetzt
und wenn sie den Menschen im
Erdbebengebiet helfen wollen können Sie
spenden beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN
de65-100-400 600 100 400 600 Stichwort
ZDF Erdbeben Türkei Syrien
Informationen finden Sie auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
sogar die Ukraine hat Hilfe für die
Erdbebenopfer Angeboten etwa ukrainische
Rettungskräfte die im Krieg ja leider
viel Erfahrung mit dem Ausgraben von
verschütteten gesammelt haben
derweil gab es in Kiew heute einen Gast
aus Deutschland
Bundesverteidigungsminister Pistorius
hat seinen Antrittsbesuch absolviert er
traf nicht nur sein Amtskollegen
reznikow sondern hatte auch einen Termin
bei Präsidentin im Anschluss daran habe
ich darüber mit ihm gesprochen doch
zunächst der Bericht von Thomas Reichert
der den Verteidigungsminister nach Kiew
begleitet hat
die Reise für den Gasthaus Deutschland
beginnt am Vorabend dann im kalten
polnischen Bahnsteig 12 Stunden Fahrt
durch die Nacht liegen vor Boris
Pistorius die Fenster des nachtzugs nach
Kiew sind mit Folie abgeklebt
Splitterschutz seit Kriegsbeginn war
kein Deutscher Verteidigungsminister in
der ukrainischen Hauptstadt der Boris
Pistorius ist das erste Mal dass er
ihnen Kriegsgebiet fährt er kommt früh
an am Morgen in Kiel
gewissermaßen
Solidarität zu zeigen deutlich zu machen
dass Deutschland auch Deutschland weiter
an der Seite der Ukraine steht im
verschneiten kieferschein selbst die
zerstörten russischen Panzer wie
Souvenirs aber nebenan der Mauer mit den
gefallenen sucht ein Soldat nach dem
Bild eines Kameraden historius hat
Blumen mitgebracht und Ermunterung für
jene Soldaten die in ein paar Stunden
nach Deutschland aufbrechen werden zur
Ausbildung auf dem Leopard 2 die Truppen
kommen direkt von der Front ernste
Gesichter die kurz aufleuchten für ein
Foto Lächeln
14 Leopard 2 liefert Deutschland und
hofft dass andere Länder folgen
zusätzlich kündigt pistoris heute die
Lieferung von älteren Leopard 1 Panzern
an ich kann ihn mitteilen dass wir uns
verständigt haben in einer Gruppe
verschiedene europäischer Länder
eines großes Kontingent von Leopard A1
zu liefern das wird in Schritten in der
Etappen erfolgen bis zum Sommer ca 20 25
über 100 soll es werden bis Anfang
nächsten Jahres Ukraine ist Präsident
selenski sagt beim Treffen er brauche
300 bis 400 Panzer und nehme alles was
er kriege aber pistorisches hört doch
noch weitergehen die Wünsche die nach
Kampfjet zum Beispiel
gesprochen unsere Verbündeten und
Partner werden am Ende entscheiden
welche Plattform gut ist für die Ukraine
historius ist gegen Kampfjets wichtig
seien jetzt Luftabwehr Panzer so wie
dieser Gepard aus Deutschland der in
einem geheimen Ort am Stadtrand von Kiew
steht drei Raketen und eine Drohne die
auf die Stadt und ihre Versorgung
zielten erzählt die Besatzung habe sie
schon abgeschossen für
Verteidigungsminister boris pistorisches
ist der Moment der deutschen Waffenhilfe
für die Ukraine am aller nächsten kommt
wenn man hier steht und das Material aus
Deutschland sieht
wie großartig die ukrainischen Soldaten
und Soldaten ausgebildet werden sich
ausbilden lassen wie schnell sie in der
Lage sind das Gerät erfolgreich zu
bedienen mit großem Erfolg zu bedienen
dann ist das ein gutes ein gutes Gefühl
das zu sehen sonst bleibt ein Gefühl wie
dieses der Ohnmacht ein Häuserblock
mitten in Kiew im November getroffen von
einer feindlichen Drohne 50 Menschen
verletzt zehn sterben und das war nur
einer von vielen kriegsscharplätzen in
der Ukraine
und der Bundesverteidigungsminister ist
uns aus Kiew zugeschaltet guten Abend
Herr Pistorius guten Abend Frau Slomka
sie kommen jetzt in diesem Moment aus
Gesprächen mit Präsident silenski was
ist die haupterkenntnis und auch
Botschaft die sie aus diesem Gespräch
mitnehmen
zunächst mal war es ein sehr offenes
freundschaftliches Gespräch kann man
sagen und Präsident selenski hat sehr
deutlich gemacht wie dankbar die Ukraine
den Partnern in Westeuropa und den USA
ist für die Unterstützung die es
bekommen die sie bekommt und das gilt
insbesondere auch für Deutschland
selensky Präsident evil war sehr sehr
gut einzuordnen und zu schätzen was
Deutschland hier in an Unterstützung
leistet das ist ja auch ein Zeichen dass
er den Verteidigungsminister den
deutschen Empfänger ist ja auch immer
diese verschiedenen politischen Ebenen
also dass Deutschland da in den Augen
Kia ist wirklich nur eine besondere
Rolle hat
das kann man ohne Zweifel sagen und das
ja auch zu Recht angesichts dessen was
Deutschland leistet in diesem Krieg
gegen die Ukraine 3,3 Milliarden alleine
militärischer Hilfe da sind die
Leoparden noch nicht mal eingerechnet
und nochmal dreieinhalb Milliarden für
zivilehilfe nach den USA ist Deutschland
da auf auf Augenhöhe mit Großbritannien
der stärkste Unterstützer und das
anerkennende anerkennt die Ukraine und
dafür hat sich der Präsident auch noch
mal ausdrücklich bedankt wir müssen
diese angekündigten Leoparden ja aber
auch irgendwie in die Ukraine kommen und
bisher nicht das richtig sehe steht
zumindest bei der modernen Version also
den Leopard 2 A6 diese europäische
Koalition noch nicht sind sie denn da
weiter vorangekommen dass auch andere
europäische Länder sich jetzt konkret
beteiligen und nicht Deutschland alleine
maschieren lassen
also beim 2 A6 sieht es in der Tat noch
nicht so aus als ob noch viele mehr dazu
kommen Deutschland ist da bislang der
größte Geber mit 14 Leopard Panzern vom
Typ 2 A6 wir sind noch in Gesprächen mit
zwei drei Ländern aus denen sich noch
was ergeben könnte aber das ist noch
nicht spruchreif und beim zwei A4 ist
dann noch mal wieder eine andere
Situation erfreuliches allerdings dass
heute die Verhandlung abgeschlossen
werden konnten zwischen verschiedenen
Ländern unter anderem Dänemark
Niederlande und Belgien die den Leo 1 A5
zusammenstellen lassen und den Stand
setzen lassen mit der Folge dass das
etwa bist Mitte des Jahres 20 sein
werden bis Ende des Jahres wird sich das
auf 80 summieren und dann im Laufe des
ersten Quartals 24 auf über 100 also
drei bis vier Bataillone auch das ist
ein wichtiges Signal dass ich den
Präsidenten heute mitgeben konnte Panzer
älteren bauarzt die jetzt den modernen
sie hätte schon auch nicht so überlegen
sind was sie eigentlich wollten waren
zwei Bataillonen mit richtig Moder
Kampfpanzern also das ist dann jetzt
erst noch mal schwierig sich das richtig
so
also bei zwei A4 bestehen nach wie vor
die Hoffnung dass wir einen zusammen mit
den zwei A6 dann ein bis zwei
Bataillonen zusammen bekommen aber das
hängt jetzt im Augenblick nicht mehr von
Deutschland ab sondern von den anderen
Partnern die sich ja vor der Konferenz
in Ramstein auch entsprechend geäußert
haben helfen zu wollen und das müssen
wir jetzt zusammentragen dann müssen wir
das die Ukraine auch auch Kampfjets
fordern Deutschland hat das klar
verneint und nicht nur Deutschland wurde
dieses Gesprächsthema heute auch noch
mal aufgebracht
nein das war heute kein Thema beim
Präsidenten Präsident zielinsky hat auf
meine Frage hin wie er denn die
Bedeutung der Luftverteidigung
einschätzt und deren Bedeutung für den
weiteren Verlauf des Krieges sehr
deutlich gesagt dass er unsere
Einschätzung teilt dass das die höchste
Priorität hat für die nächsten drei
Monate neben dem Aufstellen der
Panzertruppen das geschieht ich habe
heute hier verabschiedet eine große
Gruppe von ukrainischen Soldaten und
Soldatinnen die aufbrechen nach
Deutschland um sich jetzt kurzfristig am
Leopard zweier 6 ausbilden zu lassen
also da laufen die Dinge voran unseren
Beitrag werden wir bis Ende März liefern
können Luft Verteidigung das sind ja
unter anderem neben anderen Systemen die
deutschen Gefahren die sich an der
Ukraine sehr bewährt haben wohl und
großer Beliebtheit erfreuen aber gibt's
dafür denn überhaupt noch genug Munition
also man hört ja dass die offenbar schon
auf Sparflamme schießen die ukrainischen
Soldaten die an diesem System arbeiten
also der Eindruck ist heute hier nicht
erweckt worden dass auf Sparflamme
geschossen wird ganz im Gegenteil der
Gepard hat eine ganz zentrale Rolle hier
in der Luftverteidigung gerade in den
Städten und im Bereich der kritischen
Infrastruktur übernommen und ja
Munitionsknappheit gab und gibt es aber
auch da sind wir mit der
Rüstungsindustrie sehr weit in Kürze
wird eine neue Produktionsstraße für die
so Munition eröffnet wir haben außerdem
noch Verhandlungen laufen mit zwei drei
Ländern von denen wir möglicherweise
Munition bekommen können und außerdem
haben wir zusätzlich zu den 30 bereits
gelieferten Gepard zwei weitere im
Januar ausgeliefert und fünf weitere
werden noch folgen also auch da ist viel
Bewegung drin jetzt mal von den
einzelnen Waffensystemen wegzukommen sie
werden ja wahrscheinlich mit mit
Präsident silence und auch mit dem
Verteidigungsminister reznikow auch über
Szenarien gesprochen haben wie es jetzt
weitergeht und was von russischer Seite
zu erwarten oder zu befürchten ist die
Drohungen aus Moskau sind ja recht
eindeutig
ja die Drohungen sind das eine die Frage
der mobilbankung in Russland das andere
die Einschätzung darüber gehen
auseinander und die Befürchtung auch ich
würde jetzt ungern die strategischen
Überlegungen der ukrainischen Freunde
hier ausbreiten aber klar ist alles was
wir lesen ist auch Gegenstand der
Überlegung heißt dann aber auch Hilfe
aus dem Westen muss schnell kommen also
es geht einfach auch um Geschwindigkeit
wenn die Russen da tatsächlich eine
große Offensive in den nächsten ein zwei
drei Wochen starten
ja klar geht es um Geschwindigkeit
deswegen machen wir ja erstmal erfüllen
wir ja unsere Zusage jetzt sehr schnell
bis Ende März und hoffen darauf dass das
die anderen Partner auch sehr schnell
tun mit den zwei A4 wir werden außerdem
ja noch 40 Mörder liefern in diesem Jahr
die dann wiederum in den Verbänden auch
verbunden kämpfen können das ist auch
wichtig also wir tun alles was wir
können aber das Material muss auch da
sein und auch die Rüstungsindustrie
braucht beispielsweise beim Thema
Munition Vorläufe daran beißt die Maus
den Faden nicht ab wie groß ist die
Sorge auch dass dieses dieser
Stellungskrieg den man da jetzt im Osten
beobachten kann wo es dann einen Meter
vor und Meter zurückgeht etwas abstrakt
gesagt dass dass ich jetzt eh nicht so
weiterzieht man eigentlich nie an den
Punkt kommt wo Putin dann irgendwann mal
zu Verhandlungen bereit ist denn darum
geht es ja eigentlich
ja das ist die große die die große Frage
die uns alle ja umtreibt wie kommt man
an den Punkt dass man Putin und Russland
an den Tisch Gericht das ist die große
Frage und ja natürlich macht man sich
hier in der Ukraine Gedanken darüber wie
geht der wie geht der Verlauf des
Krieges an den in den ostlich-östlichen
Gebieten weiter welche Gelände Gewinne
gibt es und wie kann man dem was
entgegensetzen aber dafür sind eben auch
die Panzerverbände dann durchaus von
zentraler Bedeutung
danke für das Gespräch und gute
Rückreise
sehr gerne Frau Slomka
das Interview haben wir am Nachmittag
aufgezeichnet ein weiterer deutscher
Minister ist aktueller Reisen damit geht
es jetzt bei dir weiter Heinz ja der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
und sein französischer Kollege brünole
Merse sind in Washington zu Gesprächen
über die umstrittenen
us-fördermilliarden für grüne
Technologien nach Treffen mit
US-Kollegen enthalten beide mit die USA
wollten die EU-Staaten umfassend über
das Ausmaß dieser staatlichen
Unterstützung für die Wirtschaft
informieren habe ich sagte man sei sich
einig gewesen dass man nicht Gefahr
laufen dürfe in einen
Subventionswettlauf zu geraten
fragen wir nach bei Valerie Haller worum
es genau geht was hat es mit diesem
us-paket auf sich also da geht es um
eine riesiges Subventionsprogramm 370
Milliarden Dollar schwer das größte in
den USA der vergangenen Jahrzehnte ja
und auch der erste Versuch der erste
ernsthafte versuchte Amerikaner die
Klimakrise anzugehen es soll grüne
Technologien voranbringen mit einer
Prise Protektionismus denn gefördert
werden Unternehmen die in Nordamerika
produzieren und europäische Regierung
sorgen sich nun dass viele Unternehmen
künftig lieber in den USA investieren
weil sie dort auf großzügige Förderung
energiefreundlicher Technologien hoffen
können ein
Subventionswettlauf also um grüne
Fabriken und was macht man nun aus der
Situation wie geht's weiter die Hoffnung
ist dass das Gesetz Paket etwas
eu-freundlicher ausgelegt wird Beispiel
Autoindustrie nun sollen zumindest die
E-Autos europäischer Hersteller in den
USA die in den USA geliest werden auch
steuerlich gefördert wenn es klingt ein
bisschen speziell ist aber ein Brocken
50 bis 80 Prozent aller deutschen Autos
die in die USA exportiert werden sind
tatsächlich leasing-fahrzeuge die
Autoindustrie ist übrigens ein großer
Baustein des
us-subventionspakets und damit sind
Deutschland und Frankreich die beiden
Länder in Europa die davon mit am
stärksten betroffen sind ja und das
erklärt auch warum die beiden in
Washington heute vorstellig wurden
vielen Dank
einen Tag nach Beginn der
Parlamentsdebatte über die geplante
Rentenreform in Frankreich haben Streiks
erneut Teile des öffentlichen Lebens
dort lahmgelegt etwa bei der Bahn in
Schulen und dem Energiesektor in
zahlreichen französischen Städten gingen
insgesamt 100 Tausende auf die Straße
Frankreichs Regierung und der Präsident
macron will das Renteneintrittsalter
schrittweise von 62 auf 64 Jahre anheben
an den ersten beiden protesttagen hatten
sich nach Angaben des Innenministeriums
knapp 1,3 Millionen Menschen beteiligt
in Deutschland gab es im vergangenen
Jahr zwar Lohnsteigerungen aber am Ende
ein deutliches Minus bei den realen
Löhnen hat das Statistische Bundesamt
errechnet nach vorläufigen Zahlen
stiegen zwar die
bruttomonatslöhne durchschnittlich um
3,4 Prozent aber die Inflationsrate lag
bei 7,9% damit sanken die Reallöhne und
durchschnittlich 4,1%
. zum Sport ein Ergebnis von DFB-Pokal
Achtelfinale da hat der SC Freiburg bei
Sandhausen mit 2:0 gewonnen und bei der
Ski-WM in Frankreich heute die
Entscheidung in der alpinenkombination
bei den Herren gewonnen hat der
französische
und Slalom hatte er eine 10 Sekunde
Vorsprung vor Titelverteidiger Markus
schwarz aus Österreich
bester Deutscher war Simon Jocher auf
Platz 13
die Wirtschaftsgeschichte ist ja voll
von gescheiterten Fusionen selbst wenn
sich die Unternehmen die zusammengeführt
werden sollten sehr ähnlich waren das
gleiche herstellten oftmals ging das
schief mit dem verschmelzen insofern gab
es schon einiges Skepsis als RTL vor
anderthalb Jahren freudig ankündigte den
Hamburger traditionsverlag Gruner und ja
zu kaufen das genau wollten die
Fernsehmacher von RTL mit all den
Zeitschriften von Brigitte über Landlust
bis zum alternativen Fußballmagazin 11
Freunde
irgendwie sollte das alles
zusammenkommen Fernsehen Print und
Online und zu einem großen Medien
Champion verschmelzen das ist weitgehend
gescheitert und jetzt folgt der
Kahlschlag berichtet Martin Niessen
es ist das Ende eines großen
Missverständnisses hunderte Mitarbeiter
protestieren gegen die heutige
Ankündigung von RTL Deutschland den
traditionsverlag Gruner und Jahr zu
zerschlagen 700 Arbeitsplätze sollen
wegfallen 23 Magazine eingestellt oder
verkauft werden auch die für die Nina
Roberts bislang arbeitet
wir stehen jetzt so ein bisschen vor den
Trümmern unserer Arbeit wir haben alles
gegeben geben weiterhin alles haben die
Hoffnung noch nicht aufgegeben aber
sehen einfach dass es keine Visionen
mehr gibt diese Marken in die Zukunft zu
führen unter dem Dach von RTL RTL
Deutschland stellt sein
publishing-geschäft neu auf hieß das in
der Pressemitteilung des Unternehmens
mit dem Ziel die führende Position und
journalistische Relevanz weiter zu
stärken ein Interview mit dem ZDF lehnte
RTL ab was bleibt ist das ein Geständnis
eines grandiosen Scheiterns zusammen
stärker hieß es im vergangenen Jahr zur
Fusion von RTL Deutschland mit dem
renommierten Verlagshaus ein neuer
nationaler Medien Champions sollte
entstehen stattdessen nun Ausverkauf und
Stellenabbau
ist schon sehr verwundert darüber dass
Bertelsmann oder RTL offenbar nicht in
der Lage ist ein profitablen und
angesehenen europäischen Konzern in die
digitale Transformation zu führen das
ist echt krass wenn die Antwort
zerschlagen heißt dann frage ich mich
was Bertelsmann so tut mit seinem
Mediengeschäft das Kernmarken wie Stern
Geo oder Brigitte erhalten und sogar
gestärkt werden sollen macht die
Managementfehler aus Sicht von
Medienexperten nicht kleiner das hat
sich jetzt rausgestellt dass ein
Fernsehsender und ein Verlag offenbar
nicht so ohne weiteres fusionieren
können man hätte sich ein bisschen mehr
Zeit lassen müssen um gemeinsam Neues zu
entwickeln neue Formate neue Titel neue
Fernsehsendungen diese Geduld war nicht
da die Investitionsbereitschaft war
nicht da die Übergabe von tausend
Unterschriften für den Erhalt der
Arbeitsplätze an Hamburgs Kultursenator
bleibt vermutlich ein symbolischer Akt
genauso wie dessen Appell wie geht's
meine Beurteilung eines Unternehmens
nach seiner eigenen Programmatik was es
künftig geschäftlich machen will da
können wir nur appellieren in den dis
uns darüber gehen wie wichtig auch
Medien und journalistische Angebote für
eine Demokratie und für eine offene
Gesellschaft sind dass sie nicht nur
etwas sind was ich nach namage
betrachten darf der Name Gruner und Jahr
im Verlagshaus musste schon RTL weichen
dutzende Zeitschriftentitel und hunderte
stellen nun den gescheiterten Plänen des
rtl-managements
und hier geht es jetzt gleich mit der
Reportage Reihe 37 Grad weiter heute
über junge Gamer die von einer
Profikarriere im E-Sport träumen und
feststellen müssen dass das Zeitfenster
dafür erstaunlich kurz ist um 0 Uhr
meldet sich dann also in gökte mir mit
unserem heute schon mal Update morgen
gibt es ein halbzeitjournal um 21:30 Uhr
im DFB-Pokalspiel VfL Bochum gegen
Borussia Dortmund und dann begrüßen Sie
hier Christian Sievers und Hanna
Zimmermann auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend sehr unbeständiges Wetter
gibt es zurzeit am Mittelmeer aber zum
Beispiel auch hier in Portugal da dreht
sich nämlich ein Tief das Azorenhoch
dagegen das bildet eine Brücke aus bis
nach Osteuropa so ist das Wetter bei uns
ruhig allerdings kommen hier von
Nordwesten uns die tiefst allmählich
näher und deswegen wird es von Norden
auch ein kleines bisschen milder heute
Nacht ist es meist klar über
Norddeutschland gibt's einige
Wolkenfelder und die Temperaturen sinken
bis minus 14 Grad am Alpenrand das ist
strenger Frost etwas weniger grimmig ist
der Frost an den Küsten von Nord und
Ostsee bei -1 - 2 Grad und morgen liegen
die Höchsttemperatur um bei -1 Grad am
Alpenrand und sieben Grad am Niederrhein
und das wird morgen wieder ein sehr
sonniger Wintertag mit nur ganz wenigen
Wolkenfeldern in Schleswig-Holstein und
diese Sonne können sie ausnutzen die
Sonnenbrandgefahr ist wirklich gering
das sehen Sie an den Werten für den
UV-Index und Sie sollten die Sonne auch
ausnutzen denn morgen steht die Sonne
fast so lange am Himmel wie es
astronomisch nur möglich ist das aber
wird sich bis zum Wochenende ändern dann
werden doch die Wolken von Norden immer
dichter und die Sonne verschwindet
wieder schon vorher nämlich Donnerstag
und Freitag kann es hier in
Norddeutschland etwas Regen geben sonst
bleibt es bei ruhigen Winterwetter am
Samstag kann sich dann noch meine
Schneeflocke in die Mittelgebirge
verehren ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Abend